okay next up on office hours with Jason
is AJ AJ AJ a wife and he is with a
company called viral viral viral spelt
incorrectly v y RI lllll no v yr i ll
com terrible name credibly confusing to
spell but you got the calm yes it's it's
a it's a play on water marketing clearly
marketing that requires people on the
phone to spell it three times which is a
total fail and when you type it into
Google you're gonna come up last but
we'll get into your horrible choice in
domain name selection and naming in a
minute what is your biggest challenge
yeah so the biggest challenge is we sell
our video yeah explain what you do and
then X by migration yes essentially what
we do is we are helping brand marketeers
dig through all that massive amounts of
video content on social media and help
find the best video reviews and boxing
videos and all that drive conversion so
essentially we are an AI based video
discovery analytics and content
marketing platform so if I'm Sam stock
conversion so if I'm Samsung or I make
the Google pixel I can pay you to find
people who've made videos about me
correct and you all use AI to find them
as opposed to me saying on YouTube
Google pixel 3 review that's correct so
so the difference is you know what's the
difference yeah that sounds like a
marker could pay somebody know not only
so so we've actually trained machines to
watch millions of videos so we are able
to map this is what makes us very unique
we're able to map millions of video
reviews to product SKU category brand
and competitor
ok we then go inside the video and we
analyze the video through nine different
lenses so sentiment topic scene
demographic brand safety and all that
yeah yeah I do this is exactly very
relevant video that will convert so if I
am the iPhone and I see that Jason at
Jason on Twitter is talking smack about
the iPhones camera sucking compared to
his pixel 3 which I was doing when I was
in Hong Kong I mean literally just stop
taking pictures on my iPhone
you would inform them of that and then
describe the sentiment for correct
correct Oh the Apple people okay I get
it is what is your challenge yeah so the
challenge is really be sales you know at
the moment are we're focusing on two
vertical its beauty and automotive and
we're now expanding to CPG and so the
challenge I have is we have two people
right now on sales team myself and I one
of the person in LA and so the challenge
is we mostly we do outbound marketing
right now go to conferences bring in
leads from there we're now launching an
inbound mechanism to build more leads so
we actually have we have done some
pilots with some big customers we have
case studies that we're building up and
we're also launching a free search
engine so people get a taste of what's a
challenge so the challenge is how to
increase my sales how to sell tourism
product cost the product is hot a verge
on average is two to twenty thousand
dollars a month based on number two to
twenty thousand or so range is really a
SAS so has your customers pay what
they're paying right now I would say
we're at we're starting at two thousand
right now and that's my mom okay and how
long have you been selling it so about
eight months now okay so we don't know
the lifetime value yet not yet but the
good news is let's just say it costs two
thousand a month twenty four thousand
dollars a year in most cases you have a
lot of room to play with because if it's
a good product and people keep it for
three or four years you're talking about
fifty to a hundred thousand dollars and
that means you could pay I believe a
hundred two hundred dollars per lead
which means you could pay a dollar or
two per click and convert one percent
into a lead you understand how this
funnels yeah so you are the perfect
person to do content marketing that
backs into a webinar or a consultation
so what I would do is I would come up
with some viral content that comes out
every month right and you do the
sentiment analysis of the most hated
brands okay the brands that are the most
hated now you smiled and you left I got
an emotional reaction for you well
that's one of the keys to doing viral
content
we're content that gets people's
attention is that you get an emotional
response so these are the five most
hated brands this month and you say
Samsung phones you know when they were
blowing up or you know Apple when they
took away the phone jack right whatever
it is right well you say here is a
supercut you know what a supercut is no
no Supercuts a viral phenomenon on
YouTube where somebody will make a video
of a bunch of people slap together
having the same comments so it's like a
supercut of like the same moment got it
so you literally take a snake a supercut
of 25 people complaining about the
iphone removing the phone jack from
famous people to unfamous people yeah
now that goes viral and you say read the
report the 10 things people hate most
about the iPhone and the 10 competitors
who people mention most as replacing
their iPhone then you take that you make
a landing page anybody who hits that
landing page you retarget them do you
understand what retargeting is I do and
see you cookie them and you retarget
them with a white paper form okay you
have a 10 page white paper that goes
deep into this right then you targeted
on LinkedIn advertising against people
who work at those companies or their
competitors and have the titles of
president/ceo product manager marketing
PR customer service etc right now you've
got this funnel of people who wanted to
click on the five most hated things
about the iPhone or these other
competitors right and there's a form
that says if you would like us to do a
sentiment analysis on your product or
you would like to get our 10 tips on how
to not suck or 10 tips for dealing with
customer complaints whatever ones you
make right fill out this form and we'll
immediately email it to you
they fill out the form boom and if they
go to the forum page right you know
something else about them right so you
have one set of retargeting people who
went to see the viral video you go to
the other one of people who filled out
the forum the people filled out the
forum you can afford to spend $5 per
click right they have really become yeah
important players right the ones before
that maybe a dollar click and then you
have your Sales Executives having fresh
delicious nutritious high-quality you
know the
the Wagyu level leads not the ground
beef not the the crummy chuck you know
bad beef right getting the Ric the high
quality Wagyu you know yeah yeah yeah
absolutely
you just have to invest in building that
funnel right grow and then your
salespeople instead of them doing this
hard work of cold emailing a hundred
people a week they're responding to five
who filled out the form every week got
it got it
and just one the follow-up question on
that so is there something so we also
want to sell by a number of seats logins
as well is there anything marketing I
want to create a market networking
effect within once your so yeah so
here's where I'm going with that
our data our insights can be essentially
can be leveraged by social analytics and
content marketing teams got it very
simple you get one person to sign up you
allow them to comment on the data and
have like a message word feature so
let's say you have charts and stuff like
that on the top right hand of the screen
I'm looking at the chart it says invite
people from your company to discuss this
and you type they type in emails and
then they're popped in that chat room
instantly got it
or share this document with people you
share it and then they can post comments
cuz you could be like share this and
talk to your team about it you put in my
email right now I'm shared and then we
have a room and it says I J wanted to
talk to Jason about this right and it
puts that first you know icebreaker in
there now if they start having a comment
thread there and they quit the service
they have to quit the thing and you
could say to them oh I see you have 17
people commenting on this one chart if
you'd like to upgrade them so they can
see all the charts themselves right boom
so you let people comment on individual
charts but not see the entire charts
goddess then the person would have to
reinvent every chart and they're just
popping off and then at a certain point
you could say you know you can invite
people you invite up to 10 people to up
to 10 charts a month yeah and after that
you can't do right so some sort of
stickiness yeah where there's annotation
or something going on but I love that
we're in the process of introducing life
chat within the dashboard itself so
people can talk that makes it sticky
community stuff makes it's yucky ok very
hard ok and then you want to have the
charts update so that's another thing
let's say that chart adds the month of
March
yeah
it should email everybody and say this
chart has added the month of March now
you've got an engagement strategy right
right so this stuff wall takes time to
build yeah yeah but you have whenever
you have a product that makes twenty
thousand dollars a year or more well
let's just say even five thousand
dollars a year and more you know when
you're making over $5,000 a year you can
start to really do interesting stuff
when you're selling a ten dollar
subscription every month notify yeah or
five dollars a month or whatever it is
very hard by the way we just sold
$20,000 pride for four months
essentially it's because to become how a
sixty thousand dollar product and we're
up as we're building it we're upping the
yeah I would deprecated the bottom half
of your customers do not let people get
into this product right because your
your your weapons salesman your an arms
dealer and when you're an arms dealer if
you give everybody you know like the
latest fighter plane yeah it negates the
value I see you want to only sell the
bomber and the fighter planes the people
who can pay you the top dollar and then
the other people die okay and get wiped
out okay that's the product make very
good insight as well yeah I mean the
promise you're making to the marketers
who buy this is they'll be able to
defeat their competitors yeah and then
their competitors have to buy it right
and then if you don't have enough money
to buy it you die yep it's called Darwin
you know I'm just being can be you know
very helpful all right good luck yeah
how much money you're gonna make in how
much money to make it 2018 what are you
gonna make it 29 so 2018 was about 100k
great and we're actually the goal is to
by august a book about a million dollars
and book read book a million okay so you
want to try to do maybe five six seven
hundred in 2019 correct we want a five
extra revenue all right be in touch with
my team because you are starting to get
into that accelerator or moving on and
by the way we're closing the two million
dollar round and only 1.5 is in the bank
that's great so just closing the
remainder half good lamb so yeah okay
well be careful because I don't know if
we can say that a live on television may
you have to edit that part out do we
talk to your attorneys okay okay we'll
be right back with more office hours
[Music]